you have to tell the people that it's
going to be eight years till we're back
to earth
if i tell the passengers that we are
stuck up here and the food is running
out i'm gonna become the next
all-you-can-eat buffet
hello avenue 5. this is mission control
is everything okay
yeah
everything's fine
how can so much light feel so dark i
agree it's my tv show why does she agree
with everything that said to him he
hated me exactly
your sister died in space i can't look
up at the sky because it just reminds me
of her so i can only look forward or
down now
it's me welcome back iris restoring
smart seat to your default settings are
you calling me from the toilet when i do
that i'm a goddamn animal
sorry we're heading into the sun the big
yellow cancer factory made out of lava
that one
burn or starve well it's nice to have
options
you know i think i preferred it when it
was chicken or fish the twilight of the
[ __ ] tyrant is upon us
[Music]
i'm just a happy bride
say we sit here and wait for death
pray for death
some combination of sitting and death
sorry i'm just internalizing a lot of
panic and fear right now
but now i've done that and i'm back in
the room
you